so how can people take advantage of each
system socialism capitalism so for one
thing people are going to take advantage
of systems they're going to find
loopholes they're going to find ways
around they're going to find ways to to
at times
um Dominate and chorus others even in
systems meant to get rid of domination
and coercion that's why we need to
design our systems in our such a way
that that it eliminates as many of these
things as possible and also that's why
we need democracy we need Freedom so in
a Soviet system for instance you have
the rise of this authoritarian
bureaucracy that dominated and of course
others in the name of socialism
now
that system desperately could have used
some political democracy and some checks
on what people were doing and some
ability to reverse the power right and
as soon as of course little elements of
democracy was brought to that system
um the system you know collapsed uh
because there started to be outlets for
for Dissent and for dissatisfaction so I
think we can't design our priori a
perfect system we need to be committed
to certain principles that allow systems
to be perfected and for me that's the
importance of democracy so even a few
years ago not to go on a pension but
um people were allowing Chinese
authoritarianism and they're saying
China is building this efficient system
the state runs so well there's
technocratic Excellence plus there's
just productivity and they're just
working harder than Americans and and
whatever else but look at in practice
what really happened with covid both the
initial suppressing of information about
what was happening and and Wuhan and the
outbreak were many ordinary Chinese
workers and doctors and others were
trying to get the word out and they were
suppressed
um by by Communist Party officials
locally and move on properly with the
collusion naturally nationally and now
now with zero covert policies and
whatever else so I think that that often
we find that even though it seems like
these are are weak systems and and
democracy makes us less uh competent
technocratically and otherwise I think
it's kind of a necessity for systems to
grow and evolve to have that freedom in
Civil Society but as for individuals now
the first part of it is yeah I think
people should be free to make their own
choices you might have tremendous
potential but you might choose to spend
it in Leisure and Leisure doesn't only
mean doing you know sitting around at
home drinking a bunch of beers kind of
wasting your life away that way Leisure
might mean spending more time with their
friends and family
building these sort of relationships
that are gonna maybe not change the
world and some some medicines but we'll
change the lives of the people around
you and we'll change your community for
the for the better I'm taking notes here
because I for me at least you're just
about playing a lot of Skyrim this whole
family relationship then I'm gonna have
to work on that I didn't realize that's
also including Leisure because I'm gonna
have to reconsider my whole life here
hey you know Leisure should mean Civic
activity too right I mean there's that
famous book The the Robert Putnam won
bowling alone or whatever we described
it for now I mean I'm I was born in 1989
I like you know um video and computer
games you know
um so I definitely do that type of
leisure too but uh I found a lot more
richness in my life when in the last you
know decade a lot of my leisure has
returned to like going to the local bar
for like the couple drinks I have a week
instead of doing it at home alone
watching TV or something you know
because you get that random conversation
that sense of a place and and belonging
but
I guess what's the undercurrent maybe of
your question was now if you have a
system with lots of carrots but not the
whip of hay you might be destitute you
might be unemployed you you might not be
able to support yourself unless you're
you're working a certain amount would we
still be as productive would we still be
able to generate enough value for
society
um and I think that that's a question
that that is is quite quite interesting
I think that we're living in a society
now with enough abundance that we could
afford
more people deciding to opt out of the
system out of production
and that the carrots of staying in you
know more money for consumption more
ability to do cool things more just
social rewards it comes from being
um successful or from from providing uh
would be enough but that's another thing
that would have to be balanced in a
system so if we're seeing mass
unemployment by choice in a Democratic
Socialist system
then you might need to reconfigure the
incentives you might need to encourage
people to go back into production but
that's something that again you could do
through democracy and through good
governance
um you don't have to set the perfect
blueprint I'm in in motion
um you know write up a Treatise now in
50 years from now you know try to follow
it like it's scripture